okay I want to follow up on this story
that has been sort of started by Donald
Trump about banning Muslims from
traveling to the United States I have
video of Reverend Franklin Graham who
has said in the past for example that
Satan is behind LGBT rights and advocacy
he insisted yesterday to CNN that the
only way to fix the US government is
with more Christian politicians and
biblical principles and Carol Costello
followed up and said yet well let's talk
about that like what are these Christian
principles because you like Trump's
Muslim ban and that doesn't sound too
Christian to me I have the video from
CNN let's take a look at it all 50
states does one talk about biblical
principles because um you agree in part
with Donald Trump on banning Muslims
from coming into the United States is
that fair well first of all I don't
believe in banning Muslims from coming I
think we should put a halt on
immigration because our borders are
broken until we have a promise proper
system to vet people all integrase I
think all immigration but especially
people come and Hispanics Muslim
everybody but all people but especially
those coming from the Middle East right
now and we see a lot of families and no
question they're fleeing for their life
they're one in a better life but we see
a lot of young men who are military age
by themselves coming in that way as well
and we don't know who these people are
and there needs to be some proper way to
vet them so I think we should be putting
a halt on any immigration from that part
of the world until our government has a
system in place where we can vet them I
do think many Americans would agree with
you but I also think that that some
Americans look to Canada for example and
their warm embrace of these refugees and
they look at the way that some
politicians in the United States talk
about especially people from the Middle
East and they don't think that's very
Christian well I'm thinking that we have
to protect American citizens just like
the school in Los Angeles I think they
did the right thing sharp out there are
so first he says I don't believe in
banning Muslims from coming to the US I
just think we should stop immigration
from Muslim countries which is
effectively the same thing this idea of
what it means to
Christian and I'm interested in hearing
from you as a progressive Christian
right when you hear that the gaming well
yeah taking in those in need that sounds
Christian but really as Franklin Graham
says protecting the people who are here
is the Christian thing to do it is that
frustrating yeah I mean it's beyond
frustrating right they have a selective
Christianity which I guess is good if
you're going to ignore certain portions
where it says cut off the hands of
someone who steals from you write that
letter to ignore right right but I mean
it's it's good to take that figuratively
but they take the love of God of Christ
bigger Tiffany light they they sacrifice
things that are actually useful for
Humanity in exchange for conservatism
like Franklin Graham is no more a real
Christian then then hell I don't even
know who to compare him to he's a he is
a conservative Christian he is he has
bought into the conservative religion do
you think that in a sense Christianity
is being used as a tool rather than a
religion to push particular legislative
goals absolutely it's it's since 1980
since the Moral Majority came in with
Jerry Falwell it has been a
propagandistic tool to manipulate those
people who want a very simplistic
politics if you can explain their
politics in terms of their religion then
they can understand it right because
they don't want to get into the nuances
of these arguments and so Gibby them
something easy and they can buy into it
and if it happens to align with
something that feels good with them then
then their hook line and sinker well
after the break I'm going to be
interviewing Sarah hater who is known as
an ex-muslim and the stories she is
going to tell us and what she has to say
I think will be very eye-opening for
many in our audience so stay with us
were here with Ben Dixon from the
Benjamin Dixon show plenty more coming
up